that booked out with a lot of things
censorship what was what was immoral by
the standards of that time meaning in
the 1970s and 80s what is on today in
2009 anything goes it's just it's you
just have to know to look at a different
place for it when I was researching in
the 1970s to do that book that was
published in nineteen eighty the
aforementioned thy neighbor's wife
things were very visual on the streets
you can see massage parlors if you
walked up Lexington Avenue Park Avenue
even all over the city's major cities of
the United States for example you would
find massage parlor signs massage
massage bishop very open they were in
their newspapers such as the the
pornographic newspapers would advertise
massage parlors were really little more
than places of prostitution I mean we
would pay women to perform sexual acts
upon yourself it might be masturbation
it might be oral sex that might be
intercourse but you you what happened
after that aids period now the Internet
offers everything massage parlors are on
the end you can if you know how to use
the internet there's nothing you can't
get swingers mate swapping as I said the
most hardcore pornography is available
so there's no what you see when I
started to research that book some
quarter quarter century and more ago
there was a kind of a moral police
marled squad of people who wanted to
restrict the right of adults to have
access to sexual dalliance right now you
can't control it because what's happened
through the technology of the internet
is it brought the merchandising of sex
into the home and people can assist sit
there and their laptop and order
whatever they want I mean it's like it's
it's just it's just it's easy as take
out I mean you just like go on a
Kentucky Fried
chicken are having pizza send you can
get everything
now it's always been passed no I don't
mean if you can always go ahead get sex
anyway that's nothing new there's very
little new about sex this very little
new it's just different ways of
merchandising and different ways of
obtaining it if we're talking about
mercenary sexuality that's what you are
talking about now let's talk about
marital sexuality I said before and I
repeat now marriages are not going to be
held together because of sexual
performance you see all these viaja God
you can barely watch a football game
without having 16 viagra commercials
interrupt every between every exchange
of a football um that's nice I mean it's
great that there's such a thing for
impotent men as viagra and all those
other competing products but again it's
it's marriages are not going to be held
together because of sexual performance
it's not i mean the beginning as i said
the courtship period okay that's a phase
but the sexiest woman alive is not going
to be a marital mate of any consequence
if her mate doesn't respect her I mean
or that or the other way around